[Musique]
on
non
ambiance survoltée place de la
république à paris sur la scène du
département de la réunion juniors fait
bondir les milliers de réunionnais venus
fêter la musique ce 21 juin nous un
médecin après deux ans d'événements en
ligne les réunionnais n'ont pas manqué
le rendez-vous donné par l'antenne de
paris du conseil départemental de la
réunion et dès 19h le créole résonne
jusqu'aux oreilles de la statue à
l'effigié de la république chez les élus
du département la surprise se mélange au
bonheur
de constater vraiment cet engouement et
la population réunionnaise présente les
le bonheur ça procure on a on a un
sentiment de bonheur qui est incroyable
je suis arrivé ce soir franchement il ya
une énergie et j'ai partagé d'ailleurs
cette énergie avec monsieur melchior pas
ce que je dis c'est incroyable si la
réunion est là et elle pattes
massa les boeufs rougail saucisses il
faut patienter pour passer commande au
camion bar garée sur la place les
effluves de samoussas et de bouchon se
mêlent aux airs mélancoliques de
grand-mère du compositeur douce à nous
ça va frédéric joron découvre pour la
première fois paris côté seine et c'est
une belle communion avec les réunionnais
non
voir les réunionnais
pleurer sur les champs qu'ils ont connue
il ya dix ans en arrière
j'ai comme l'impression que c'est une
bouffée d'oxygène et puis il faut dire
qu'il y avait le kobe dossier avant donc
les gens on y voit qu'ils ont soif et
puis nous on est dans notre élément il
aime ce à quoi ils aiment la musique
puis moi mais moi je découvre la place
de paris je découvre tout ça avec les
gens je suis déjà venu en touriste mais
c'est pas la même chose la musique
réunionnaise comme le maloya qui est
entré dans dans l'unesco et tout ça donc
et une reconnaissance des ja il ya des
valeurs qui sont il ya des accents qui
sont mis donc pour nous c'est tout c'est
tout bénef et puis voilà quoi c'est la
musique du soleil
soleil chaleur musicale un petit air
d'océan indien en plein paris les
sourires sont à la mesure de l'attenté
des réunionnais de région parisienne
privée de kabar pendant deux ans à cause
de la pandémie de coheed
chez nous ils nous rendent bien
il faut tellement plaisir de se voir sur
scène je ne lâche pas je donne je donne
je d'art et d'artistes qui se produisent
ce soir sont ils sont aptes beaucoup de
fatigue et beaucoup de respect beaucoup
de talent
au prétoire
j'ai même été bravo à laudun de paris au
département d'avoir gagné aujourd'hui
l'objectif est de leur proposer tout une
vitrine aux artistes de la réunion doit
faire réunionnais tous ces artistes au
sein de la métropole il ya eu cette
crise de public est passé et là les gens
ils ont envie vraiment d'oublier sur
mauvais passage et de s'amuser
la fête de la musique est revenu donc
c'est le moment de s'amuser là c'est un
plaisir de reprendre de reprendre les
scènes moi j'ai commencé à l'âge de 18
ans 18 6 9 ans du coup en 2010 a fait
pas longtemps
donc j'ai connu directement c'est monter
monter en puissance après il ya eu un
traitement avec le covin on est on est
tous passés par là mais là là c'est
juste un actif de pour prôner en plus
ici à paris qui aurait pensé c'est ça
qui fait
ses choix avec sur scène dit jamie 6h ou
jean marc barr et les générations font
le grand écart et médéric venus de la
réunion avec deux danseuses fait le
bonheur des plus jeunes quand ils
répondent à la question quel artiste
préféré
j'ai parlé
[Musique]
j'ai été extrêmement bien accueilli donc
ça fait chaud au coeur je suis très
content déjà d'avoir pu représenter en
quelque sorte les de la réunion même là
ce soir c'est exceptionnel c'est un
privilège pour moi c'est un honneur
aussi d'être là l'ambiance la musique
une salle rassemblement s'était
tellement plaisir donc voilà ils sont
tous dans l'ambiance était vraiment
géniale 22 heures c'est le moment
attendu du tirage au sort avec deux
allers retours à la clé les gagnants
sont aux anges et ne sont pas les seuls
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fin de soirée magique pour ce premier
jour d'été à paris juniors redonne
l'énergie de danser
[Musique]
après plus de deux heures trente de
concert les spectateurs sont prêtes à
recommencer dès demain
tous les jours tous les jours c'était
trop bien parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
prêts à réaliser
des super temps franchement on a adoré
l'élite les chanteurs étaient géniaux ça
nous a permis de voile à des rencontres
et a créé rôle d'éclaireur fallait un
petit peu notre langue est
l'événement fausse arvier mai prochain
le rendez vous est donné dans un an si
tout va bien d'ici là les images de
fêtes circulent encore dans la tête des
réunionnais de la capitale
[Musique]